14th of October 2022 and 44 migrants are
crossing the channel to England the
Smugglers have packed them in tightly
every extra person means more cash is
[Music]
speaking in Disguise goni told us he
paid Smugglers 3 500 euros he's one of
more than 12 000 albanians who've
illegally crossed to England in small
boats this year
foreign
was deported back to Albania a few days
later but his story is a common one
videos of trips are easy to find on
social media as our Smugglers adverts
for cut price Crossings
[Music]
and their tempting offers for many in
the northeast of Albania
this is the most deprived corner of one
of Europe's poorest countries
wages are low jobs are scarce people
want to escape
Albania is a small country with a big
problem the population here is around
2.8 million yet the government says
every single year since 2011 on average
42 000 people have left and that's
turning communities like these into
ghost towns from Albania we go to
Scorpio with few prospects at home Alex
is among thousands who paid Smugglers to
take him to the UK where he worked
illegally for years if I have a chance
we go right now to England not just to
England just to move from Albania here
doesn't have no jobs or nothing you know
and you're gonna work like 10 hours from
10 10 pounds basically so it's no life
here albanians admit this lack of Hope
fuels migration but the Albanian prime
minister told me the UK home secretary's
claims of an invasion aren't helpful
what makes me wonder more is that I
never heard an apology
feel like Albania needs an apology from
the UK when you apologize
it's okay it happens when you don't
and
when you avoid it then it means that you
want something from what you said
so it means that there is a calculation
behind it means that you you really are
talking to to to to a certain uh number
of Voters
that want to hear this and you are
feeding them with this because you need
their votes
while tens of thousands of albanians
live legally in the UK more and more are
risking their lives at sea without
renewed hope at home and better
cooperation from abroad they will keep
on coming Siobhan Robbins Sky News
Albania